I saw you two weeks ago I'm in New York
and I run into you and you're your
co-star mark-paul yeah mark-paul
Gosselaar and we were all chatting and
it occurred to me that you know
mark-paul Gosselaar and i are chatting
and you you guys were quiet you were you
weren't speaking it on No what's your
problem man well I'll tell you you guys
were talking about cycling yeah you guys
are talking about bicycling yeah and and
well I have a car so I cycle but I just
let you two nerds go to work it was the
cutest thing they were both talking
about the Garmin's and the little things
and they're biking and by clean you
couldn't humiliate the whole sport more
by calling it by Klink my father is a
huge cyclist mind that mark-paul is the
son my dad wishes he had so right oh
that's sad yeah I actually Franklin and
bash aired last night we premiered last
night this morning
mark-paul was sitting with me doing a
radio thing you looked at me as they go
out he goes your dad just text me I
haven't heard from my dad
good job pretending to be a lawyer or
anything like that right but he hit up
Mark Paul now so you said you don't you
don't ride bicycle that's what do you
write just a car I write a car I have a
motorcycle a motorcycle so I write a
fast version of a bike with a motor on
it yeah yeah it's sexier it's let's be
honest motorcycling is cool and it's not
I'm sexy but I'm not I'm relatively new
to it and that I learned two very
important things which most people
probably already know sneezing with a
helmet is really really dangerous and
really but what happens you're in there
and you it's awful yeah it's Thunderdome
in there you don't want
and then the other is and this is just
this is user error I should have known
better
you don't chew gum and blow bubbles well
you weren't really doing that what
straight up was yeah yeah my second
helmet I won't do it it my first one I
did it in because I did you almost you
could probably that's you're good you
could die
cuz you feel a bubble and then suddenly
just the world is paint yeah and you're
going 90 miles an hour on the freeway oh
my that fast but I'm going fat I'm going
faster that I should blowing a bubble
yeah and it also is just not cool like
if the paramedics have to take your
helmet off and it's all pity for you no
not at all alright let's talk about let
you die at that point let him go do not
resuscitate